الآن، نفس نظام الطقس الذي كنا
نتحدث عنه للتو والذي يضرب
اليونان يتسبب أيضًا في حدوث فيضانات في
شمال غرب تركيا، وقد قُتل شخصان على الأقل
هناك وفقد أربعة آخرون وتم
إنقاذ ستة
مركبات عسكرية وطائرة هليكوبتر
تقوم بتفتيش المناطق الحرجية بعد 12 دقيقة.
قيل إن الناس تقطعت بهم السبل بسبب هذه
الفيضانات، بيل وير هو كبير
مراسلي المناخ في شبكة CNN، وقد قدم
لنا تقارير مكثفة في جميع أنحاء
حرائق غابات ماوي مؤخرًا في فلوريدا
أثناء تكيف الإعصار مع هدير،
ولسوء الحظ فاتورة العديد من الأماكن الأخرى
التي قمت بتوثيقها لنا
لسنوات حتى الآن ولكن من الواضح أنه
كان واضحًا جدًا في الأشهر القليلة الماضية
في الساعات القليلة الماضية، أعني بيل،
انظر فقط إلى اليونان بشكل صحيح آه أولاً، إنه
يلخص الأمر أولاً، لقد كانت لدينا هذه
الحرائق الشرسة التي اجتاحت
للتو الأحياء والريف
و  ثم قم بتقسيم الشاشة إلى
الفيضان الملحمي
بعد بضعة أيام فقط، أعني كيف
تصف بالضبط ما تعرفه من اضطرابات
في العالم
الآن، إنه كوكب مختلف باولا
عن الكوكب الذي نشأنا عليه، إنها
دورة مياه مختلفة الآن، هذا هو ما  لقد
حذرنا العلم من أن ذلك سيحدث إذا تمكنا
نوعًا ما من الخروج من
درجة الحرارة المعتدلة التي
تطورت فيها كل الحضارة الإنسانية ونعم، إنها
تلك الضربة المفاجئة من الجفاف
الشديد هناك في اليونان إلى الآن
تعرف ما يعادل سنة أو شهرًا من
الأمطار  على أولئك الذين يعانون من ندوب الحروق، حيث
لا توجد فرصة للمياه
لإغراق التربة على الإطلاق، وهذا
يزيد الطين بلة وقد رأينا
ذلك مرارًا وتكرارًا في ثلاث أو أربع
قارات